I thought one strange was bad enough
so there's been another League TV spot
trailer for Doctor Strange in a
Multiverse of Madness so let's break it
down the trailer begins with Wong saying
you've opened a doorway to the
Multiverse before we cut to new footage
of wonder in the first shot we see a lot
of flames in the background and a lot of
rubble so possibly a lot of Destruction
has gone down possibly caused by Wonder
and Jesus walking through the Havoc
which she has possibly caused which I
always say there's a good chance that
she has just by judging from her facial
expressions here she has this very
Sinister looking face here kind of proud
of what she has done they've been cut to
another shot I've winded with a similar
setup she's walking away from someone
that's been causing in the background
she's a lot of blood on her she's
definitely had some action of some kind
and she is very very serious looking
something very very big is going down
and possibly she isn't even done
fighting she could be walking towards
someone injured on the floor she may be
walking towards her next opponent but
whatever has happened I would assume
there's been a lot of casualties we then
have new dialogue from Wong saying I
thought one strange was bad enough
referring to the different variants of
Doctor Strange this then cuts to a scene
between doctor strange and Sinister
strange doctor strangers see an
attacking Davos range before he deflects
the attack which goes back at Doctor
Strange and hits him show him the
Sinister strains may be more powerful
than the strange that we know as he is
able to deflect the Spells used against
him now that's it for the new footage
from this TV spot this one was quite
sure but we do have two new images that
we'll release the first one was of
America Chavez she's looking at
something in the distance and then the
second image is of Doctor Strange
America Chavez and Christine Palmer they
seem to be in some sort of tunnel of
some kind they all look concerned and
they're looking at something in a
distance or someone in the distance
whatever they're looking at is a bit
concerning to them you can even see
Christian Palmer put her arm down to
make sure people stay put I wonder if
they're looking at a variance of some
kind but I'm not sure let me know what
you guys think in the comment section
below what are they looking at and with
that out of the way that's pretty much
everything for this video so if you guys
did enjoy please like And subscribe and
turn notifications on to show your
support thank watching